living up to his promise to be one of
the most progressive presidents ever
and it's still not enough for the far
left the so-called centrist
is now under pressure to go nuclear to
raise the minimum wage to 15
an hour bernie sanders pressing biden's
budget office nominee
will you at this point commit to doing
what president biden and i and many
others want to see happen
and that is help us move to end
starvation wages in america by raising
the minimum wage
over a period of several years
absolutely
and squad member cory bush says 15 bucks
an hour
is only the beginning you know we have
to
start with a 15 an hour minimum wage
it's the start
like it should be higher than that right
now but that's where we are so
we have to at least give people that
well greg
way more than 100 000 restaurants went
out of business last year i guess that's
just not enough
yeah i'll get first off we've got to
address the new phrase
starvation wages okay the idea that
people in the u.s are starving when
40 of young adults age 20 to 39
are obese uh the number goes to forty
five percent when you're my age
early forties um but you can make you
can make an
argument about the minimum wage without
suggesting the other side wants you to
starve people to death
so let's not give in to the to their
language and people forget what minimum
wage is to your point about restaurants
it's the starting point not the
finishing point you're only supposed to
be on that first rung
for three to six months we all made
minimum wage i made 300 3.35 cents an
hour
and you couldn't wait to get up higher
it was actually
incitement really positive incitement to
work hard
and the point is always forgotten by
these economic deniers
that someone at that pizza joint already
makes 15 bucks
and he's been there for a year so when
you raise the minimum wage for that
entry level
what do you got to do for everybody else
including that other guy
you got to raise their salary too
because you can't have the minimum wage
be the same as that other guy because
then he wasn't making minimum wage
before
so goodbye pizza parlor which is what
you saw happened and we covered in
seattle i think it was seattle or with
the state of washington
when they raised the minimum wage and
all the all these you know local
restaurants went
or kaput dana not only does it destroy
jobs one
1.4 million jobs but to greg's point it
actually
raises prices for in in food businesses
and in service businesses and so
if you've got inflation the people who
still have jobs
are paying higher costs less of their
money in their pocket for
fun things well then if you make that
argument then what
um people that support the 15 minimum
wage or more
as congresswoman bush does they will say
well yes some people might lose our jobs
but these many more people will be
lifted out of poverty
um so you have this binary situation
actually
nobody really has made any new political
arguments about this it's just the same
old thing we've
dealt with this before um but here's the
thing if you think back to
january 20th what's one of the first
things that president biden did
kill the keystone pipeline he's taken
many
very left left-wing positions through
these executive orders already
but when it came to the minimum wage he
said on the super bowl interview he did
with norah o'donnell
i actually don't think that's going to
be in the bill and you know we'll try
another time and he seemed okay with
that
but what did chuck and nancy say oh not
so fast
we're going to do it anyway and they are
pushing forward so
no matter what he does to the for the
left it will never be enough
if you give a mouse a cookie he's going
to want a glass of milk i think that's
how that story
goes i do wonder if there's a way for
somebody out there to explain
in a better way what people really want
they want opportunity economic
opportunity the ability
to move up and maybe there maybe there
is something that needs to be done there
and conservatives ought to take a look
at that and do a little bit better i
think president trump
looked at that and tried to figure out a
way to do that a little bit better um
but it can't just be the fact that you
some people are going to
lose their jobs but some people are
going to be lifted out of poverty so
okay that's great
no that's not great uh juan do you
but the issue is to dana's point is that
people the cost of living in many states
we're a series of regional economies and
small economies the cost of living
in the 20 states that have the federal
minimum wage
right now the cost of living is so low
you
businesses can't afford to pay at
somebody working at a gas and sip
what somebody makes in new york city or
san francisco
as a minimum yeah right so i think that
in fact you hear from joe manchin he's
for example saying you know should be
around 11 in his opinion in west
virginia the state he represents
but i just wanted to say off the top
that this is no
radical proposal in the hands of the
radical left
i believe i have here 83 percent of
americans
they can say 725 is just not enough
half of america supports 13 to 15
or higher and as dana was saying we know
this would pull millions of americans
out of poverty and raise the wages of
others
so and i just want to emphasize this
point you were making about the states
because several states
have minimum wages higher than 725 right
now
you take a state like florida
conservative leadership in the senate
the governor
they they right now have a ten dollar an
hour minimum wage and
in last november's election they raised
it they voted to raise it in the next
five years
to guess what 15 so
to me this is evidence americans see
this
as a good thing it has not wrecked
economies
in the several states that have raised
their own minimum wage it has not had
the impact you're
talking about on restaurants or business
it just hasn't and
by the way in terms of aoc and bernie
because i think they have to deal with
senator manchin they have to deal with
senator cinema
i mean i mean these are people who are
moderates they're not buying into any
radical agenda
it's because it's not a federal 15
minimum wage different states get to
choose
what their minimum wages are and jesse
900 000 people would be lifted out of
poverty
just to correct that but again you know
who
gains from this amazon amazon aoc
amazon and target right the who have
gotten bigger and more powerful in the
last year so you're going to crush small
businesses
and hand more power to jeff bezos like
he needs it
do you know what the poverty level was
before the pandemic
10.5 percent that is the lowest
poverty rate in american history
happened under donald trump
donald trump brought more people out of
poverty
anybody since 1950 so if you want to
bring people out of poverty reduce
regulations reduce
taxes and make america competitive in
the international arena
it was the new york times juan that said
under donald trump
in 2019 medium u.s household income
69 thousand dollars adjusted for
inflation
it's the highest record we've ever had
since we started keeping records in
nineteen sixty seven
you know who benefited most blacks and
hispanics
that's where the wages grew the most
rapidly
and the black poverty level went below
20
for the first time so record low black
and hispanic
and white poverty and record high
wages and a record amount of people in
the workforce so if democrats want to
fight poverty
and give people a raise just do what
trump did
if you really care that's what you do
amy jesse we're talking about thirty
thousand dollars that's what minimum
wage at fifteen dollars would equal
fifteen dollars i'm talking about the
whole country one
yep you eliminate entry-level jobs and
the opportunity for people to rise up
and make money and grow and be
prosperous
up next